this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
thank you for joining us here on eight
news now i'm john langler we are
following breaking news this morning in
the death of review journal
investigative reporter jeff
german right now metro police are at the
home they are searching the home of
clark county public administrator rob
tullis in connection to the crime 8 news
now i-team reporter vanessa murphy live
at the scene of that search near
charleston and wallapy vanessa these two
men do have a history
yeah john and you can see this is an
active scene as police search this home
media is being kept about a block away
as police search the home in this
homicide investigation now a couple of
key things to note here jeff gearman had
done several stories on public
administrator robert tellis and
corruption within his office he then
lost the democratic primary yesterday we
showed you video of a vehicle police
were looking for the suspect vehicle
this gmc yukon our photo journalist shot
video of a vehicle just like that one
here earlier at the home of telus here
metro police also released video of the
suspect you can see this person is in
disguise wide brim hat construction type
clothing metro police say the suspect
had been casing the area prior to the
crime
long time review journal investigative
reporter jeff gearman was found stabbed
to death outside his northwest valley
home saturday morning police say he was
killed friday morning so again this is
an active investigation as police are
still here at the scene 8 news now has
multiple crews on this story we'll keep
you posted reporting live vanessa murphy
8 news now
vanessa before we let you go it's all we
should focus on the fact that mr tell us
in addition to a lot of other
interesting aspects of this sad story he
is still an elected official at the
clark county public administrator's
office do you know anything about that
aspect of the investigation
we do have a crew over at that office i
believe that police are over there or
were over there earlier today but again
he still is an elected official but he
lost that primary john i'll send it back
to you all right vanessa thank you very
much as we'll continue to follow this
story all throughout the day here on 8
news now online and the 8 news now at
noon thank you for joining us